[Music]
welcome to your weekly ticket
work-from-home edition all right huge
news if you were into the visual trip
that is Doctor Strange because Sam Raimi
has announced he will be taking up the
sequel Doctor Strange in the multiverse
of madness now Sam Raimi is no stranger
to comic book movies as he directed
spider-man 1 2 & 3 those are the ones
with Tobey Maguire and also still my
favorite Raimi made the announcement
while promoting his 50 states of fright
anthology saying I love Doctor Strange
as a kid but he was always after
spider-man in Batman for me Raimi takes
over for the director of the original
Doctor Strange Scott Derrickson who
actually took to Twitter in full support
of him I've worked with Sam Raimi one of
the nicest people I've known in the film
business and as a director a true living
legend what a great choice to take over
Doctor Strange I look forward to seeing
it in theaters November 5th 2021 and
Emmy award-winning director Reed Morano
is in talks to direct Jennifer Lopez in
the godmother the film is based on the
true life Colombian drug lord Griselda
Blanco and will be distributed by STX
films Lopez will star as Blanco and
produce alongside Elaine goldsmith
Thomas Benny Medina and Julie yorn STX
films and Lopez also collaborated on
second-act and hustlers and a lot of
movie release dates are in flux and are
moving around but Paramount Pictures
says that their feature top gun maverick
is still on course to hit theaters
December 23rd 2020 the director Joseph
Kosinski told comicbook.com we are
sticking to our schedule and finishing
the movie just as if we were coming out
on its original release date that was in
the summer
luckily I'm in the homestretch of
post-production where despite all the
restrictions on how you can work now I
am able to continue doing my job and
finish the movie which is pretty amazing
that is kind of awesome
he's like working on Top Gun from home
and Steven Spielberg's West Side Story
which is also set to be released this
December just released these first look
photos into the musical remake the film
stars Ansel Elgort Rachel Ziegler Ariana
DuBose and II got winner and star of the
original film Rita Moreno who will be
playing the newly created Valentina all
right let's do a set change and get some
help for this next part but maybe you're
stuck inside looking for something to
watch and you need some recommendations
well that's why we're here and I've got
a special guest today Rotten Tomatoes
correspondent Mark Ellis mark what do
you got for us
okay oh if you're like me you've worn
out all your video game systems
including this game boy that now has no
back to the Tetris cartridge and so I'm
trying to think okay what's another
board game that I can do if I go back to
that era then I'm like what's a good
board game movie oh wait
clue and it holds up so well like a lot
of other 80s comedies pale in comparison
because the physical humor is still
there the script is still as sharp as it
ever was
and it's just such a fun murder mystery
comedy they do not make movies like this
anymore tale they're thinking about
remaking clue but if you go back and
watch the 1985 classic you're gonna say
nobody should ever touch this property
again it's perfect wow I did not see
that one coming I've never seen it I
might check that out actually that's
great please do and then as soon as you
watch it text me and let me know your
thoughts because I trust your comedy
instincts I think you're really gonna
enjoy this movie it is a gem that's
great awesome yeah I've got I've still
got the high off of knives out so that
should be that should work for me then
better than knives out hot take better
than knives out well let me do my
recommendation speaking of unexpected
I picked trolls World Tour I had a
completely different movie up until last
night and I put it on out of curiosity
I'm trying to support all the movies
that are being released for theatrical
rental it is so creative and so
beautiful if you are a fan of animation
they do some really clever
in this that is just visually worth
watching like for example the
heavy-metal trolls at one point she
tells some liked stories via heavy-metal
patches on a black denim jacket and so
they like tell there's just all these
creative choices um different textures
for the music videos they do it in
different filming styles at one point
one guys running away and they do that
like front mounted camera on one of the
trolls they don't have to this is a
digital movie it's just there's a lot of
creative choices I didn't expect to like
it it's a lot of fun if you you know
just check it out like if you're curious
and you love animation check it out
the closest thing I have to a troll on
my collectors desk is this is a pop toy
that my niece made for me for my
birthday so that's that's my troll oh oh
my five-year-old niece sees me kale oh I
mean it's a little off it's pretty close
she got the teeth right you got this all
right cool all right well thank you Mark
Ellis hey great seeing you buddy and in
the words of Clue I'm gonna go home and
sleep with my wife
available to watch at home today is the
turning what happened to your last nanny
like I'd tell you need to take charge
here Kate
I know what you're afraid of keeping the
lights on motif you see Kate Mendel
played by Mackenzie Davis takes a job as
a nanny for two young orphans at an
isolated Gothic mansion in the main
countryside she soon learns that the
children miles and flora are emotionally
distant and unstable when strange events
start happening to Kate and the siblings
she begins to suspect there is more to
the family's story the film is a modern
take on Henry James's novella the turn
of the screw and also stars Finn Wolf's
heart and Brooklyn Prince two of the
coolest names in the industry Wow
but if horror isn't really your thing
check out it man for the finale for this
beloved martial arts saga is available
to watch at home on Fandango now so
you're a teacher I am a teacher I teach
Chinese going forward like a gymnast yes
something like that following the death
of his wife it man travels to San
Francisco to ease tensions between the
local kung-fu masters and his star
student Bruce Lee while searching for a
better future for his son the film
earned over 100 million at the box
office in China out grossing the newly
released get this star wars the rise of
Skywalker oh and it's also fresh with a
90% on the tomato meter so it's
definitely worth a watch well that's it
for this week let us know what you'll be
watching and if there's anything else
that you think we should check out and
I'll see you next week I can't believe I
had all this stuff to do this like well
I might as well try to go around the
block
you
[Music]